uh we're a Silicon Valley team like me
and my co-founder we both grew up in the
B area and one of the core ethos of
Silicon Valley is to build things that
customers want to solve problems that
customers have something that we Tred to
stay away from is over engineering for
the sake of building cool technology
which I think is like really common in
crypto interestingly um there's a lot of
projects out there that are building
pool tech for the sake of building pool
Tech the the problem that you really
want to solve is what are the existing
problems with the user experience right
now and how do you improve those
all right guys bang bang I've got Jay
here uh Jay I thought a great place to
start this conversation is around the
evolution of l1s if we go all the way
back to you know 2008 2009 Bitcoin
really was the first layer one and it
came out and it was the idea and promise
of becoming electronic money I think for
the most part people are very excited
about Bitcoin it's still kind of the
king when you look at market cap
dominance Etc but vitalic boan and
others said hey Bitcoin can't do
everything and what if we take the idea
of this blockchain layer one and we add
in smart contracts and we got the rise
of ethereum and kind of everything that
happened on that platform since that day
there's been an explosion of interest
and development of l1s say which you're
co-founder of is one of those kind of
l1s that's really going after this and
so can you help us understand like how
do you look at the L1 landscape and its
Evolution from the launch of Bitcoin and
ethereum to maybe what it looks like
today yeah I mean honestly I think so
far there have just been three major
chains that really matter um the first
one is obviously Bitcoin as you
mentioned and I think it was really
interesting because that helped kind of
unlock this idea of a blockchain um
before then this kind of like
distributed ledger to solve this kind of
problem no one had really thought about
solving it in the same way um so I think
that was the first kind of major unlock
um the second thing that happened was
ethereum introduced this idea of a um
basically a turn complete State machine
like people are able to write smart
contracts that in theory are able to do
anything the only limit itation around
that are this component this concept of
gas um which kind of make it a quiter
and complete uh virtual machine and I
think that was like a major unlock
because it allowed you to build anything
that you wanted to on top of the state
machine itself um I think since then
there's only been one other major unlock
uh which is in my opinion salana um and
what salana really did is it helped make
crypto accessible for everyone um
through building really high performance
infrastructure and the reason that high
performance infrastructure is important
is because when you make a lot of the
optimization that Tana did um for
example by supporting paralyzation it
helps do two things um the first is it
makes gas fees much cheaper so it makes
it much easier for people um to access
the state machine during periods of
higher congestion like on ethereum if
you're spending like $100 for
transaction fees you end up excluding
most of the global population from using
it um in salon's case it's much cheaper
than that so I think that is one side of
it and the other side of it is just the
type of activity uh specifically the
type of decentralized application that
you're able to support um it's very
restricted on ethereum L1 and I think
building this high performance
infrastructure um really allows you to
explore different design spaces as
developer so it allows for fundamentally
new types of application to get built so
that's where we've been so far um the
question then is like what direction is
the industry moving in uh going forward
so I think there's been a lot of
different types of um things that people
experimented with um I mean we've seen
different experiments with people trying
to build these share security type of
l1s for example like book do Cosmos
hubell um their ones um I think there's
also been people experimenting with
different consensus mechanisms while
still offering similar types of virtual
machines um and there's also been folks
that have been trying to just build new
virtual machines entirely uh for example
the movie ecosystems um in terms of what
I'm seeing right now I think there's
essentially a couple of core things um
the first is is that the evm is here to
stay uh the evm is what kickstarted a
lot of the activity that we're seeing on
chain right now and it's really
difficult to uh to replace the aeral
machine and the biggest reason for this
is that there's already a ton of lockin
um to the evm because it's not just a
piece of technology it's more of an
ecosystem and everyone that builds on
top of the evm um they're essentially
not only getting that technology but
they're also getting that entire
ecosystem of users existing applications
other developers um liquidity so it
becomes really difficult to replace that
uh the question is then like what is
missing from the evm right now well if
you look at ethereum L1 um it's not very
scalable and if you look at like the
ecosystem of rollups around it as well
like you're not really able to get more
than like 30 to 50 transactions per
second um which is really low by the
standard of what applications really
need um so if you kind of look at it
that way there's this pretty big design
space where if you're able to scale the
evm um then you're going to really help
unlock the kind of things that I talked
about to Solana except on a much larger
kind of um skill and that's exactly what
we're targeting with sa2 right now um we
want to build the first paralyzed ubm
and by doing this we're going to be able
to get the both uh best of both ethereum
and Salo um with support for the evm
while also having this really high
performance
infrastructure so there's a couple of
things that I think maybe will help for
us to clarify for the audience the first
first is um paralyzation how would you
describe that to like a 5-year-old right
what exactly is that people keep hearing
about it there's like oh this is the new
thing that's coming what is that and why
is it so important in terms of taking
the best from some of these other chains
for say
V2 yeah yeah so perhaps not maybe an Eli
5 explanation but maybe like an Eli 10
explanation um the way that computers or
so if you look at the Ean virtual
machine right now the way way that it
works is if you have 100 transactions
let's say each transaction would be like
me trying to send you money you trying
to send someone else money um if you
have 100 transactions they'll all get
run one after the other so this is
really simple like it's really easy for
software Engineers to um write software
that'll handle this um the issue is that
it's not performant so Modern Hardware
like the phones that people might be
listening to this on laptops that
they're listening to this on um they
have multiple cores and they're able to
support multiple work streams at the
same time so like if someone um I guess
any kind of application that they're
using right now there's going to be
multiple things running on their laptop
for example um so I mean if you think
about it like there's already this
Modern Hardware that is capable of doing
more so it's kind of silly That We're
Not Making use of that to enable um
better performance for blockchains I
think Solano is really the most
successful example of this so far of
being able to use multiple cores to be
able to get better performance um the
ethereum virtual machine like if you
look at the evm lens Cape no one is
doing this right now and I think there's
a couple of issues like a couple of
reasons for that um the first reason is
just that it's really complex to build
it up um there's also things that like
trade-offs that come with that in terms
of like increased state so then you need
to think about how to account for this
increase dat um but we think these are
all solvable problems so we
fundamentally think that the evm needs
to become paralyzed and when you're able
to do that you're able to get a 100x
Improvement in throughput so it just end
up it really does end up being a step
function improvent on the
evm so before we get deeper into kind of
what say and say V2 is um one of the
narratives which I think are very
important uh across the crypto ecosystem
that has been uh becoming more prevalent
is that uh all of the altcoins and other
chains are R&D for Bitcoin Bitcoin is
going to create l2s side chains a
variety of different approaches but
you're going to be able to issue some of
the coins uh do many of the same tasks
ET ET on top of Bitcoin in some form or
fashion um it looks like there is at
least developers that are trying to do
it what is the big difference in your
mind as to why things like this can't be
built on top of a Bitcoin regardless of
L2 side chain Etc versus having to go
build something that's new whether it is
salana say or or some other uh
approach yeah that is definitely an
interesting question I
mean so I I think the most fundamental
reason is that each piece of technology
is created for a very specific type of
use case and trying to add a new
functionality on top of that it's
essentially trying to fit like I forget
the phrase over here um fitting a square
peg into a round hole um you can make it
work it might be functional from an
engineering standpoint um but it's not
going to be the best type of um product
that gets built it's also not going to
be offering the best type of user
experience so I mean if you kind of take
a step back uh we're still con value
team like me and my co-founder we both
grew up in the B area and one of the
core ethos of Silicon Valley is to build
things to customers want to solve
problems that customers have and
something that we Tred to stay away from
is over engineering for the sake of
building cool technology which I think
is like really common in crypto
interestingly um there's a lot of
projects out there that are building
Cool Tech for the sake of building Cool
Tech I'm sure you can probably think of
probably a half dozen on the top of your
head um and yeah I mean it just seems
like it's the the problem that you
really want to solve is what are the
existing problems with the user
experience right now and how do you
improve those and the most clear problem
that we're seeing from the ux right now
um is everyone is using the evm there's
these limitations in the evm in terms of
gas cost and in terms of the design
space the developers have so let's
really focus on improving that because
that's what's going to cause the biggest
deck function change um for improving um
dbn so when we then go and we look at
what SE is doing there's a lot of techn
teal tradeoffs right and we can almost
evaluate this maybe as like what do you
think ethereum got right got wrong what
do you think salana got right got wrong
and then what do you all doing in terms
of these decisions and how are you
thinking about tradeoffs around security
transaction throughput Etc to come up
with what you think is kind of the the
best you know mix of the ingredients if
you will to really serve users yeah so
in terms of what ethereum did right um
as I was mentioning before they like
introduced this idea of a turn complete
virtual machine um so that's a really
complicated way of saying that like
you're able to build stuff on top of the
virtual machine and you can build it
however you want to there's not going to
be any limitations in terms of the types
of functionality that you're able um to
support so this really I I think was a
major major kind of new introduction um
because being able to try smart
contracts in this decentralized way um
it really expands the design space of
what people are able to do um the thing
that I don't think ethereum got right uh
was they didn't really build it with
scaling in mind um from the get-go like
the focus was not to support um much
higher amounts of activity happening on
the network I think they had long-term
plans for like okay we're going to be
supporting execution charting right now
they're looking into um a rollup Centric
future but when they were initially
launching I think that wasn't really a
core Focus point of theirs um which I
mean to be fair I think that is
definitely the right way of building um
because when they initially launched
there was not really an example of a
train complete virtual machine either um
that was used on a blockchain so I think
they were really trying to focus on that
initially um what I think salana did
right is they were able to help scale um
a blockchain to be able to support
greater throughput um what I don't think
that they like what I think they should
have done instead of supporting the svm
is trying to use the evm and then making
it backwards compatible um so people can
take existing L1 smart contracts from
ethereum deploy them to solo with no
code changes and if they had done
something like that I think it would
have resulted in a much more seamless
developer experience much more seamless
user experience and it would have
resulted in kind of a much um uh easier
time uh for people to both build and uh
use Solano so that's why I think that
opportunity in the middle of being able
to take the evm and helping scale it in
the same way that's laed it um that is
quite significant so in terms of the
trade-offs with an approach like that um
I think the biggest issue that comes up
with paraliz
is it leads to increase state so what is
state right um state is all of the
balances um that are there uh for both
uh normal accounts so this would be like
I have 10 say you have 20 say um and
this would also be all smart contract
balances um so all smart contract State
um so like this Unis swap smart contract
has um these pools and this is the kind
of information tied to those pools so
there's like this idea of the state tree
which is used to compute the state hash
um and you basically need to keep this
entire state tree uh on each of these
validator nodes to be able to compute
the state hash and when you have more
transactions that are coming in this
leads to more state that gets created um
which then leads to a couple of
different issues uh the first is State
Storage like it just becomes much more
difficult to store the state especially
if you want to have lower node
requirements um and then the second
issue that comes up is it becomes quite
difficult ult to start running a new
node um because if you're trying to sync
like 100 gabes worth of data while
there's new blocks that are being
processed at the same time um it adds an
additional complexity so there's a ton
of work we needed to do from the state
side um to be able to better support uh
easier uh stage things and better State
Storage as well and so what is now going
to be possible talking about
applications or use cases that you all
see really kind of driving right so I'm
a developer I'm looking at all these
different uh opportunities to go build
uh on top of what could I possibly be
doing that would make me lean more
towards building on sa versus maybe
somewhere else today's episode is
brought to you by espresso the maker of
the world's thinnest portable display
now listen up if you're like me you feel
like you are at a command center when
you sit down at your desk I got a
gazillion tabs open and different
windows for different activities there's
my web browser my text messages I've
slack open and I got a Notes app I
normally work on a desktop and it can be
very very productive but everything
falls apart the second I leave my desk
if I'm traveling if I go to a coffee
shop to do some work or just want to
work from the kitchen table my laptop
doesn't have enough screen space I lose
my command center and my productivity
falls off a cliff it's a major problem
but this is where espresso comes in they
have a portable screen that is so
beautiful that you think Steve Jobs came
back from the dead to create it the
thing is incredibly light it comes with
a nice stand and the user interface is
so easy that I figured out how to do it
in less than 3 minutes if you listen to
this podcast you know that's not an easy
feat so so the espresso team and I we
became friends I got to know them cuz I
really like the product and those
screens they now want to offer them to
any fan of the podcast so we struck a
little deal here's how it works anyone
who listens to this podcast can go to
us.
P.O or that's too confusing just go
click the link in the description if you
go to espresso's website they've got a
brand new offer there sitting for you
you get a little discount and you'll get
a beautiful screen trust me I use mine
every day you'll love the espresso
screen and I think it'll make you more
productive go check them out today by
clicking on the link in the description
yeah I mean if you look at uh developers
out there right now um they're basically
all evm developers and anecdotally
speaking um like I've been through this
process before of like talking to evm
developers and um just seeing what their
thoughts are about moving to New
ecosystems um evm developers do not want
to go to new ecosystems um one reason
for that is there's like this idea of
ethereum alignment where they don't
really want to go to a new ecosystem
because of that um but there's also this
idea that like new ecosystems have their
own quirks I'm already familiar with the
evm and if I try to build something in a
new ecosystem let's say I write
something and move um and I make even a
small bug then my entire contract can
just get drained my entire project can
just die because of this one small bug
so it's a really SC scary kind of um
proposition for them to move somewhere
else so EVMS or developers they're
primarily attached to the evm right now
um and if you think about it that way
like the these Engineers they are
basically limited by what the evm is
offering them so I was mentioning before
um if you look at the landscape of evm
chains um mml1 rollups as well you can't
really get more than 50 TPS so this
leads to anti patterns that developers
need to use to build applications on the
evm um one example of this would be an
automated Market maker um if you look at
traditional financial markets there's
not really a concept of an amm um
because it's not as capital efficient um
and it has a bunch of other uh downsides
as well um in traditional financial
markets you would see people using order
book exchanges right um the reason that
people can't build order book exchanges
is because you can't really support that
on the evm so what say fundamentally
unlocks is any type of use case Beyond
50 TPS um right now the entire the
landscape is quite small in terms of
what it can support if you're able to
remove that 50 TPS bottleneck and expand
it to be higher um the design space for
developers just changes fundamentally um
a few examples that I can think of off
the top of my head right now of
applications that you could start to see
um one of them would be like just fully
onchain orderbook based exchanges um
another example would be a game where
you have every single action that is
happening um getting written on chain
instead of only having some kind of
token movement um that ends up occurring
on chain um another example would be
some kind of social application where
every single activity that the user
engages in like every single like
comment whatever retweet um all of that
and all their metadata also getting
stored on chain so I think it really
results in a lot of different things
that you can actually have be verifiable
um on chain instead of needing to have
most of it just be stored off chain and
then uh trying to really just store like
maybe token transfers or something on CH
let's talk a little bit about uh kind of
the the organization building on top of
the technology right you can build great
technology but you still have to do some
other things um how are you all thinking
about going in educating people in terms
of developers and explaining to them how
they can use this uh what's been working
so far and are there one or two things
maybe that people are building on top of
it that you're like yeah this is a
perfect example and and we would love to
you know just get a hundred more or 200
more of uh these types of projects on
top of the
chain yeah so I mean say V1 went live on
August of 2023 so this was around 6
months ago um and initially there wasn't
actually that much activity that was was
happening on the chin um then afterwards
The sav2 Proposal got put out in
November of 2023 so a couple of months
ago um and I think that really stuck a
chord um with the community and since
then on cv1 there's been a ton of
activity uh that has started to happen
um if you look at the stuff that's
already happening on sav1 um I think it
falled under largely three buckets um
one of these buckets was inscriptions so
initially there started to be a ton of
inscriptions activity on say and I think
this is true for all other ecos systems
but in the case of say there was no
outage or like downtime that happened um
because the chain was just able to
handle that kind of throughput that we
were seeing um since then I think
inscriptions activities largely died
down and now we're starting to see more
nft activity um and more kind of token
projects that are launching um and more
trading activi that's happening so right
now on sav1 a lot of the activities side
to um people that are trading on chain
um in terms of sav2 the kind of
Developers so I mean first of all in
terms of like the value proposition um
for developers I think it's very
straightforward like every single
developer that I've talked to has
basically just understood it uh the idea
of being able to offer greater
throughput um with the evm it makes
sense to Developers for multiple reasons
like especially evm developers they've
gone through the process of like using
eel1 and paying gas fees over there so
from more of the normal user standpoint
it is just fundamentally different and
it's a 10x improvement over there um and
also from the actual uh building
standpoint you're able to support um as
I was mentioning different types of
applications so developers become
excited about that idea as well um in
terms of new projects that are going to
get built on say as a result of this um
we're seeing two things happening one is
blue chip projects from ethereum um are
actually just straight up reaching out
to us about deploying instances on sale
so this would be like a project on
ethereum that's already launched on
ethereum L1 and is also going to be
launching an instance onay um I think
that's definitely exciting because it
results in existing their applications
being able to get cheaper gas fees and
allowing different types of um
activities for their users um and we're
also starting to see more homegrown
applications homegrown in the sense of
people that are just dedicated
completely to sit um they're launching
their own in-house kind of applications
so maybe we could talk a little bit in
terms of the um financing like you guys
raise some money token goes live how do
you think about value acrel right in
terms of private markets public markets
um and the holder base obviously with
the Bitcoin ETF getting approved people
are excited because institutions and
kind of bigger funds are coming into the
space just talk a little bit as to like
how you thought about funding the
business until now and then who do you
think is actually holding the token Etc
in the market yeah yeah so in terms of
I'm associated with Saabs um Sal laabs
is the open source development company
in terms of I mean how we rais money we
initially raised money we had our seed
round in that we announced in August of
2022 um this was led by multi-coin
capital and this was and honestly right
after the collapse happened um so it was
definitely not an easy time um to be
raising back then as I'm uh sure you can
kind of empathize with um but we were
super happy to get multicoin around the
table um I think they've been offering a
ton of very thoughtful advice in terms
of um just building
infrastructure um since then we uh
raised a series a um that was announced
in April of 2023 uh so some of the
biggest checks in that round were um
jump distributed Global and there are
several other partners that were around
the table there as well um afterwards
August of 2023 is when sa Foundation uh
helped have the distributed launch um
for the say Network and yes say Network
so say is an L1 blockchain um it's a
proof of state blockchain so there's a
token that is associated with that and
similar to like Salon or ethereum um the
types of use cases would be largely the
same um so one of them would be to help
uh secure the network so you'd be able
to STI it with the network um another
example would be for governance so to be
able to vote on any proposals to come in
um another use case would be for
transaction fees um but I think one
thing that's really interesting about a
chain like say where there's a lot of
trading activity that's happening um is
there ends up being a lot of Meb like I
was looking at a a flip side dashboard
for me recently like me on say and
there's already been millions of dollars
of me ons which is kind of wild like
there's just a ton of whenever there's a
ton of trading volume it results in lot
of um opportunities for me and I mean
for any listeners that might not be
familiar me is the value you can acue by
changing the ordering of transactions
within a block so either by having one
transaction go before another having a
transaction go after another or
potentially including or excluding
transactions from a block um so I mean
there's several different types of me
but um the core idea is that there is
some value that gets created and if
you're able to set up a redistribution
framework where that value gets
redistributed Ed to uh the chain itself
so for example to people that are
staking on the network um then it
becomes a very effective way to longtime
monetize the network um instead of
needing to have inflation for the
network um because inflation isn't
really the best approach necessarily
like you want there to be some amount of
inflation but trying to subsidize every
single validator every single node
operator on the network through
inflation um isn't necessarily the best
approach but if you have some kind of
more sustainable value cruel mechanism
such as me um then that does result in a
much more long-term sustainable
Network how do you think about the
future in terms of say you know you guys
have V2 what does this look like in five
or 10 years is it a winner take all and
say is the the king of you know got a
smart contracts and and evm Etc um is it
win or take most and maybe there's three
or four winners or do we have this like
plethora and there's you know 5,000
different platforms that people are all
building on top of and maybe in each one
of those scenarios like where to say fit
it yeah so I mean first of all in terms
of what we have um how we think about
say uh right now we think there's a
massive disconnect between web 2 and web
3 like if you go and try to do something
in web 2 it's really simple from a user
experience standpoint and every single
part of the process has largely been
optimized so far um if you try to do
something on web 3 that is definitely
not the case like it's a much more
comtent process um so the world we
imagine in a few years ideally is one
where as a developer um if you try to
build something on Say it'll offer the
same type of developer experience as
building it in a web 2 fashion um and
from user standpoint we ideally want the
user experience to be identical um to
that at building in web 2 so I mean we
want to just completely bridge that Gap
in terms of how we see the landscape um
kind of moving in the longer term uh I
do think it's going to be a win or take
most markets uh win or take most market
and I think there's going to be two
different types of um infrastructure
that ends up existing in the future
there's going to be a small number of
general purpose chains that end up
having a line share of the activity um
currently these are chains like is the
rml1 and Salo um in the future uh if
we're able to see a lot of the stuff
that I mentioned playing out in terms of
more developer activity happening as a
result of sav2 uh one of these uh bigger
chains uh could definitely be safe um so
I think it'll be a winter
most market for these general purpose
chains I think there will also be some
application specific chains depending on
the use case um but I think it's really
difficult to make an application
specific chain workor um both from the
actual product standpoint and also from
the community building standpoint um so
I think there's only going to be a
handful of those that are successful and
the amount of activity happening there
is going to be much lower than the
activity happening on these general
purpose
chains so another interesting idea is
like um maybe this difference between
digital native assets and then kind of
real world assets and this comes up
every couple of years um right now it
seems like most of the success has been
coalescing around natively digital
assets yeah real world assets is that a
thing can it happen on say is that
interesting to you all is it something
that you want to happen on top of SE how
do you think about
those yeah so it's definitely something
that can happen on say it's something
that I think should happen on say um in
particular like say it's going to be
better place for any type of I mean
honestly any type of token based
activity to happen um because it's just
a much more skillable Network so uh
there's there are projects in the
pipeline that are building um real world
assets um the question of whether it's
interesting and whether blockchains in
general are the place for that activity
to happen um I think that's something
that's still kind of up in the air um
especially if yields are low I there
there's like a lot of stuff that doesn't
really need to be built on chain and I
think often times people try to force it
to happen on chain through real world
assets um I think right now that
interest rates are high there's a lot of
projects that are trying to offer um
essentially like higher interest rate um
stuff on um but as soon as those yields
start to go down I think it's going to
be interesting to see um what happens
with a lot of these rwa projects um but
I mean in terms of experimentation in
the design space I definitely think folk
should experiment there um and I do
think say is going to end up being one
of those places where that
experimentation is much easier to
facilitate if you had 30 seconds with a
developer and they asked you you know
why should they build on top of SE what
is h kind of your pitch to
them yeah I mean the biggest thing that
stands out uh is you're able to have a
much bigger design space as a developer
um you're no longer limited by 50 TPS so
you're able to build much more um
elegant applications where you don't
need to have any anti- patterns that you
make use of to fit the constraints of
the1 and I mean this honestly is
something that has resonated with a lot
of developers um just being able to
explore this bigger design space makes
their lives easier and allows them to
build uh potentially much more
interesting types of applications for
users that um that makes sense and so
when you look at um maybe what you guys
are uh doing today what is the biggest
risk or where is the potential biggest
like pothole in the road right A lot of
times we talk about all the positive
things but as the founder of an
organization you think a lot about how
do I kill the risk how do I mitigate
that risk to to Ure
success what are those things that
you're most worried about or trying to
mitigate yeah so I mean for any type of
L1 I would say crypto infrastructure
more broadly there ends up being a
couple of different things that matter
um the first is the technology um the
second is the ecosystem so developers
and the third is community so like end
users of this technology um from safe
standpoint right now I don't think
technology is really that big of a risk
at this point um like there's already a
core like sav1 that is like and Sav You2
there's been a ton of progress happening
towards that so that's definitely not
something that keeps me up at night um
the biggest things are just uh ecosystem
and Community I mean I think Community
is honestly the thing that's most
difficult to um basically acquire to
create um because there's so many
different types of infrastructure um
having your infrastructure be the one
that people actually care about um it's
really tough to set that up I think in
st's case we actually had a really wild
kind of Journey in December so around a
month and a half ago uh where there was
the saan meme that took off um and for
any listeners that might not have been
following on crypto Twitter back then um
sayyan is from Dragon Ball Z um it is
the kind of alien race that like Goku
and all the other main characters um are
and it sounds really similar to say so
folks started just meing about that um
and it really started taking off and
then since then there's just been a much
stronger Community that's been emerging
on S um I think one example exle of
activity you start seeing with the
stronger Community is nft activity um
because nfts tend to be things that
people have much more an emotional TI to
um and you start to see a lot more nft
activity happening in these ecosystems
where there is like uh legit communi
that are forming um nfts also tend to be
a lot cheaper to trade um and they
require a lot less sophistication to be
able to trade compared to potentially
token um token based projects so yeah
like or fundable token based projects
but yeah I think that's been super
interesting to see come together and
once you start having an organic
Community um then it really incentivizes
ecosystem to get formed so more
developers coming in um but yeah I mean
if say does not end up succeeding in the
three-year time frame um I think it'll
be a combination of not enough
developers to come on um and not enough
Community there's able to get formed
where can we send people to find you
online or find out more about SE yeah I
mean to learn more about say you can go
to say's Twitter so SEI NE w r k um and
in my case you can just follow me on
Twitter as well so j a y n d r aore
jog awesome Jay thank you so much for
taking the time to do this uh it's
obvious that you guys have been pretty
thoughtful about what you're building
here and uh it looks like lots of
developers are starting to pay attention
so uh best of luck in the future we'll
definely do it again cool thank you man